don't you think you have some sort of a
telepathic relationship with dogs i
think i do
i think i think that's what my um
previous life i think that's what i was
man i go up to the meanest toughest dogs
joe yeah and i break them
it could be a real mean tough dog and
i'll be like let me go talk to him i'm
not walking back in the living room and
sit
he said he's never sat like that before
i know what did you do to him don't
worry about all that
i've always been pretty good with dogs
but some dogs are just you can't take a
chance with them the big ones not even
some of the big ones like there's some
medium-sized ones that are real sketchy
like belgian melon wasps oh yeah
that's not a big dog no i'm somewhat
american though all that european [ __ ] i
don't do all that those are the they're
they're called meat missiles yeah you
got to talk to them in a different
language i don't speak that [ __ ] we're
never trying heroin heroin heroin
you got your own mic yo i can't prepare
come play with me man
don't [ __ ] play with me joe i'm
prepared today give me give me a let me
i can use your ass right sure okay
perfect thank you we're family yeah
get in there we'll do